si brigitte c'est une question très
importante que des brigittines un peu
évoqué tout à l'heure aujourd'hui nous
assistons à un véritable déni de
démocratie
je veux témoigner pour la question des
nouvelles régions j'appartenais à une
région champagne ardenne qui a été
ballottée qu'ils devaient être regroupés
à un moment avec la picardie mon cher
eric et ça n'a pas plu à l'un des
ministres du gouvernement dans la nuit
nous avons changé et on nous a mis avec
le grand test
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé aucune
étude d'impact économique
socio-économique rien eh bien on assiste
à la même chose aujourd'hui pour les
intercoms dire que les préfets dessine
les cartes d'interco dans leurs bureaux
sans demander l'avis des élus avec
évidemment évidemment une influence une
incidence extrêmement politique
donc ça ça n'est pas acceptable alors
est-ce que sur ce sujet nicolas veux tu
veux dire un mot